[Applaudissements]
françois restons debout salut casinière
tu viens te joindre à nous nous allons
faire est juste mais bien c'est à dire
non non non je voudrais seulement te
poser trois questions à trois questions
et je t'écoute oui et bien voilà la
première s'est dit assassiner le roi
henri iv
vous avez une idée
tu as raison c'est ravaillac rien bons
liens de zèle
ensuite
quel est le grand marie-france surnommé
l'empereur à la barbe fleurie
non mais tu vois que gémir tout le monde
connaît sauf toi ensuite alors qu'un
sens qu'un c'est l'année du terrible
très bien c'est marion casimir tu sais
que mourinho et en italie à quelques
kilomètres de milan pour l'euro alors ça
ça m'est complètement égal
pourquoi ne nous demandent cela
rien dit merci les enfants au revoir
casino
alors les enfants jouent au jeu des
mimes aujourd'hui on va me met des
métiers
tu veux commencer alexandre avait dit
entre garde
regardez bien chez vous un regard des
biens etc semblent essayer de deviner
son hymne autres gardes
[Musique]
et regardez bien regardez bien moi je
crois que j'ai deviné
m il repère les maisons donc c'est un
peintre en bâtiment
c'est ce alexandre
c'est un peintre qui repas les maisons
un peintre en bâtiment bravo tu l'a très
bien faire tu vas en faire un flan ce
vase y mettre en place
à faisait 2 pour le faire
la regardez bien chez vous les enfants
florence mime un métier
pour laisser les enfants qui sont
cherchés continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que c'est camille mes enfants
surtout pas parler on fait uniquement
des gestes regarder gasquet florence
voilà
alors vous allez trouver la réponse
c'est france très bien kata soir
emmanuel tu nous en fait
si besoin d'un compère pour faire tomber
m
regardez bien
chercher chez vous
encore un petit peu au secours ça
alors qu'est ce que c'est mon docteur
docteur
qui voulait en faire une voulait en
faire un un buzz qui nous regardent
[Musique]
il a fait trois numéros observez bien ce
qu'il fait parce qu'il fait les jeux ce
avec beaucoup de détails continuer
encore un petit peu
alors attendez d'un jardinier toi
agriculteurs
jardiniers tu viens tu veux en faire un
nom
qui offert un mime j'en ai encore un
autre patiente en garde
et bien continue
et c'est que c'est pas facile de
bien me mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être laurence
peintre non peintes c'est ce que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est
alexandre explique maintenant explique
en faisant les gestes d'asie
dis ce que tu fais
dessinateur
qui veut faire un autre mis mon nom est
choisi
tu t'appliques bien à faire les gestes
qu'ils aient fait avec beaucoup de
précision réside
[Musique]
en la regardant
ça nous fait très bien son beam chercher
chez vous
kelvin est
très bien alors il répond sans sa
boulangère
il ya d'autres réponses
pharmacienne qu'est ce que c'est
attention les voilà moi je te dis qu'il
faut la casse et puisque tu n'arrives
pas relevé le bouchon tu tu as raison
c'est d'une bouteille de vin
non non non non vous feriez mieux de
boire du jus de fruits c'est bien
meilleur pour la santé qu'il veut pas
pouvoir quelque chose cette bouteille ne
contient qu'un tout petit peu d'eau
salée et un parchemin je dois être un
naufragé qu'il a lancées à la mer
lamballe a trouvé ce matin sur le bord
du rivage
il faut lire le message qu'elle contient
c'est bien mon avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est pas toi dépêche-toi
celui qu'il y trouvera ici le plan du
trésor de y'a qu'à voir par un trésor
qui s'élèvent à plusieurs millions 13
euros ça y est nous sommes riches nous
sommes rien
ne te réjouis pas trop mon poste en bas
nous n'avons pas le moindre sou pour
faire le voyage jusqu'à l'île de yas
qu'avoir par la presse que c'est de ne
pas faire d'économies on ne peut tout de
même pas abandonner plusieurs millions
sous prétexte que nous n'avons pas les
sous qu'on faire le voyage tu sais comme
on dit l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
il n'y a qu'un et changé notre plan ce
sera une petite compensation et
l'échangé en plus en france je donne
deux salles aide en échange
moins quatre ans arabe je donne aussi
salades et si on jouait la crème je
donne un panier garni je viens de le
remplir en allant faire mon marché lit
là dedans du fromage
des gâteaux secs au litre de jus de
fruits une boîte de chocolats et en
prime deux paires de chaussettes de
laine
dont pige abandon marché conclu
on voyage monsieur martin bon voyage dit
leonard oui tu crois qu'il va aller
jusqu'à là bas jusqu'où y'a qu'a voir
par là c'est par le long du nil où se
trouvent un trésor si le nom de la
boutique où j'achète toutes mes forces
et attrapes
bonjour ma très chère amie bonjour
monsieur 19 vous avez vu casimir
aujourd'hui est bien la dernière fois
que je les ai vus et ils étaient avec
françois et les enfants je voudrais pas
vous effrayer cher ami mais je crois que
cette fois à 30 pauvre kazemi est devenu
complètement fou vous dit complètement
faux complètement faux
pas du tout j'ai remis pas du tout on
les rencontre dans le petit bois il ne
m'a même pas vu la faille orthez un
arbre et de plus il n'a même pas daigné
répondre à un salut des plus courtois
que je lui ai présenté il parlait à
haute voix tout seul et qu'a raconté
t-il il parlait de ravaillac et de
charlemagne quel rendez vous tous les
deux à marignan à ça on n'y fait c'est
très étrange écoutez la dernière
personne qu'il ait vu c'est françois
allons trouver d'accord
françois tu que tu veux faire est
consacrée oui oui avec plaisir continuer
à jouer son moi je reviens dans un
instant alors voilà messieurs disney
vient de rencontrer casimir et il pense
qu'il est devenu fou comme manquer
casimir est devenu fou complètement fou
montserrat qui il parlait de ravaillac
de charlemagne qui avaient rendez vous
tous les deux à marignan six des neuf
cases il n'a jamais pu parler d'un tel
rendez-vous d'auto riez vous de ma
parole ne met pas du tout monsieur du
snob mais sans doute avez vous mal
compris
casimir est venu me poser trois
questions première question qui a
assassiné le roi henri iv ah oui à 16 c
ravaillac et finalement deuxième
question quel est le nom du roi des
francs surnommé l'empereur à la barbe
fleurie oui charlemagne très bien et
enfin dernière question quel est le nom
de la célèbre bataille qui s'y
déroulaient en 15/100 15 3 passes et
marine y voilà voyez monsieur des snobs
et vous ne venez pas du tout devenu fou
mais simplement il allait trouver ce
petit truc pour se souvenir des trois
réponses
tu m'a rassuré je retourne à mon coeur
va très bien je constate encore une fois
avec amertume que j'ai raté une occasion
de me taire je salue bien je suis apte à
lui
puisqu'il est susceptible comme
j'ai gagné
j'ai gagné j'ai connu que cela s'il
désignait les aînés ont gagné il est
arrivé quelque chose ah oui j'ai gagné
le grand concours 1 quel concours le
concours du journal de l'île aux enfants
avocat senior bravo c'est formidable
qu'est ce que tu as gagné je ne sais pas
encore un casimir l'année dernière le
gagnant a eu un énorme gâteau cerise et
au championnat
j'espère que tu vas partager ton cadeau
avec nous amélie n'en est pas question
si j'ai gagné ce concours c'est que je
lai méritait donc je garderai la
récompense pour moi quel égoïsme
enfin dean ou moins casimir quels
étaient les questions a dit je voudrais
savoir ce qu'il demandait évidemment
casimir je te demande s'il est question
était difficile oui aux fourreaux
difficile tu c'est une question à partir
du moment où on connaît la réponse c'est
facile la lame enfin casimir dino par
exemple c'est pas moi la première
question la première oui on attends tu
[Musique]
écoute enfin de toute façon ça n'a pas
d'importance puisque j'ai gagné
vous avez quelque chose à nous dire
monsieur 10,9 oui mon charme j'étais
assis au bord de l'eau
admirant l'immensité de la mer la
douceur du coucher de soleil en tout à
coup elle me futé émile campagne tombe
sur moi il revenait déçu car il venait
de perdre au grand concours de la
gazette de nos enfants
deviennent ma chère amie vous voulez
sans doute parler de ce lourdes ou de
kazimiya cocteau coque comment est ce
que vous vous feriez de demander les
gens c'est de mon savoir oui je doute
mais vous m'insultez alors parfaitement
désarmés mais de combien je vous en prie
tous les deux écouteurs que cannes
voulait pas que vous disputez monsieur
du snob expliquez-vous calmement c'est
très sain manche à rami
lisez ceci
concourt de la gazette de l'îlot
z'enfants première question qui est
assassiné le roi henri iv de ces
questions quel est le nom d roi des
francs surnommé l'empereur à la barbe
fleurie
la troisième question
exactement alors qu'as tu à répondre à
cela
excusez moi mais je crois qu'il est
temps d'aller chercher mon cadeau
casimir et cécile plein avant de nous
promettre à tous de partager ton cadeau
entre tous et les enfants compris
bon écoute et plus tard je ne peux pas
faire autrement la presse
tout à l'heure si cet anime enquête au
chocolat y en aura beaucoup trop on ne
pourra jamais fini ne vous inquiétez pas
ma chère amie avec lui tout ce ne sera
jamais assez
peut-être mais ce n'est peut-être pas un
gâteau ou c'est peut-être un voyage
autour du monde
partiront tous ensemble que merveille
je te demande d'arrêter immédiatement
j'ai joué de la grosse caisse enfin il
n'est pas bon donc annonce si au superbe
superbe soit gentil casini reprends ton
cadeau il va jouer un petit peu plus
mais on vient enfin françois m'a demandé
quoi mène de partager mon cadeau avec
tout le monde enfin c'est ce que je fais
écouter
[Musique]